are you Pro conversion therapy very much
so yeah I actually run a conversion Camp
myself I do I actually was but stole the
gift by Jesus I realized that um my
Cooter your cooter it actually has
healing power oh it can actually extract
devil demons oh my God usually that
demon is a homosexual demon though
exactly so this let me get this straight
you have a conversion therapy camp and
the gay man they come and then they they
come back and the demon yeah be uh your
cooter exactly interesting but that's
not sex right that's okay it's
conversion so I'm still a virgin so how
many men would you say you've converted
at this very moment I'm like 250. yeah
wow you're really doing the large work I
am and that's what I've been telling
people I'm like the true Christian you
mentioned that you had a horse STD with
250 conversions I wonder no STDs because
I'm telling you it's not like sexual
it's divine right